You are Sauron are you not
I'll serve you over then. Whoever you are.
Welcome backeveryone this will be my full Lord of the Rings
The Rings of Power Episode 5 video there are
a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel I'm doing videos for all the
episodes be sure to subscribe to get them careful
for spoilers from the episode if you haven't seen
it yet we'll start at the beginning and work our
way through shop by shot talking about Easter eggs
and WTF moments starting with the episode titled
partings it's a reference to the splitting of all
the main groups the new minorians who go to
Middle Earth the southlanders who leave the
main group and bend the knee to Saron and Adar
it's also a book reference to the Return of the
King chapter six which is also called partings
where the fellowship all heads off in different
directions temporarily because eventually the
story brings them all back together and that's
kind of what's Happening towards the end of season
one as well like the southlanders who were broken
apart will eventually meet again because the war
is basically going to cover the last two episodes
of season one the actual opening scene is with
Nori in Meteor Man explaining the nomadic history
of her people the harfoots and all the places that
they travel to season to season Winters and old
Force which is actually really close to where
the Shire is eventually going to be the habits
are their relatives biologically but the actual
Hobbits don't show up in Lord of the Rings until
after the third age most of the other places that
they mention are new places that they created for
the show but they're just part of this area of
the map like they show you their Journey along
the map and they do this every single year the
whole thing with the hard foots is that meant to
be a stark contrast to the hobbits who basically
stay in the same place like they all stay in the
shower that's a big thing during the Lord of the
Rings books and The Hobbit that the hobbits do
not leave the Shire as opposed to the harfoots who
do nothing but leave like they spend all the time
going all over the place meteor man's language
is getting better he's starting to understand
basic concepts in their language the whole thing
with them not understanding the concept of death
until recently I think supports the idea that he
was part of the Mayar before this like he could
be one of the Wizards the istari who are like
a subgroup of the Mayar later in the episode
he seems confused by the damage to his physical
body when he defends the hard foots I think the
whole idea is that he's just getting used to
occupying this physical mortal body one of the
big deals with with characters like Gandalf the
other Mayar who walk around in human avatars on
Earth is that the powers are severely limited
and their bodies are exactly that their mortal
bodies they can be killed but as you saw during
the Peter Jackson movies when they die they're
essentially just reincarnated like their Spirits
live on that's how powerful they are they're like
Cosmic beings that for a brief periods are trapped
in Mortal bodies walking around as avatars but
that's probably why he's so powerful and why
he's so confused about the physical damage to
his body and why he accidentally winds up hurting
Nori like he's just not used to walking around in
this Mortal body during this early conversation
he also reiterates that he's good that could be
a misdirect but I think the whole idea is that
they're meant to give him a very Gandalf kind of
vibe like he's meant to be a good character but
does a lot of really scary very terrible things
like I said the whole thing later in this episode
they want to show him being a little bit darker I
also think that's meant to be a misdirect and it's
just the idea that he just isn't used to operating
in this physical body on the Mortal plane but
ultimately he does want to help the harfords
but he does does have this Grand Mission that he's
on like the star chart that he's following trying
to find the place where Mordor Mount Doom will
eventually be that's why throughout their Journey
they show him staring at the stars more and
more as if he's still plotting his course using
the constellations like everybody in the story is
slowly converging on this place in the Southlands
where Mordor is going to be the numenoreans are
there the Orcs are headed there and the Meteor
Man is eventually headed there one of the other
classic Tolkien things that they tried to add to
this scene too with the Harvest early on is that
they have Nori's friend Dilly singing a song and
one of the big things that differentiates Tolkien
from other fantasy literature this derivative
of tolkiener was inspired by it is that there
are a lot a lot of songs in tolkien's stories
maybe if they were like 20 episodes in season
one you'd have more songs they even end the
episode on another song the one that Dilly is
singing early on is meant to be a metaphor for
Nori and meteor man's call to action and their
true purpose to find Mordor based on his star
chart that he created and also be a metaphor for
halbrand for Galadriel the new Korean characters
who are heading to Middle Earth this big call to
action from everyone is also happening with the
southlanders too because the rondier is trying to
give Bronwyn and Theo this big call to action the
southlanders who stayed at the tower you need to
hold out like they're setting up a very Two Towers
Battle of Helm's Deep situation in the last two
episodes where you have this really small group
of people holding out against this insurmountable
Force Of Orcs waiting for reinforcements and just
like in Helm's Deep like Gandalf came riding
in with reinforcements they have a wizard who's
on the way to help and also reinforcements but
coming separately from two different places I'm
sure we'll get to the last two episodes there'll
be a bunch of Helms Deep jokes that people are
telling they reveal a brand new group of people
who seem like a group of Mages or magic users who
find meteor man's crash site and they look really
evil like they're giving off over-the-top levels
of sinister Vibes so I think this guy is just
meant to be one of the followers of Sauron like
he is a follower of Darkness of morgoth but he is
not Sauron himself they have another scene of Adar
evil guy monologuing explaining his plan for the
last couple of episodes and I think he basically
explains the plot to us in this like he reveals
what's going to be happening the last two episodes
when he says soon the sun will be gone he's
probably talking about the plan that they
have to blot out the sun in the Southlands area
here in Mordor itself using Mount Doom like he
probably plans to use a combination of magic
maybe with the sword in an eruption from the
volcano in Mount Doom to throw enough Ash into
the sky to literally block out the sunlight so
that orcs can move about freely without fear being
hurt and when he says that soon the part of him
that felt the warmth of the light will be gone
there's also a reference to the storyline with
the myth roll in the elves slowly dying at like
The Light Within them slowly dying out the light
of the silma rules but I also think when Adar is
talking about the light he's talking about the
light of the two trees in the flashback to valinor
and young Galadriel like he could have been one of
the elves living in valinor when that happened
back at the Watchtower when Bronwyn gives them
the big call to action about what they're facing
she references their true king that's a reference
to Halbrand it's also kind of a reference to
Sauron as well because the old man of course sees
the dissenting voice he's the person who wanted
Theo to come with him to serve Sauron and Adar he
called Sauron their true king soon our true king
will return then this whole storyline with isildur
trying to become part of the faithful the force
that eventually goes to Middle Earth I think is
to create more of a morally gray backstory for
him they want to show that he has a little bit
of Darkness inside him because he winds up lying
his way into the forces that go to Middle Earth so
even though they're portraying him as this very
hopeful character like he's meant to be a good
character obviously we know about the end of his
story there's this big Fall From Grace he falls to
the influence of the one ring of power so during
the series we're just seeing a sealder on the way
up it's the Fall From Grace that the Peter Jackson
movies cover I think the reason isildur's sister
is making such a huge deal about not sending the
faithful to Middle Earth isn't about her being
anti-valor or Auntie elf so to speak I think it's
more about her being afraid than her father and
brother and her other brother who is in the show
they mentioned him but we haven't seen him she's
probably afraid that they're going to die and
that's why she doesn't want them to go it's not
that she hates them helping Middle Earth and they
also show you more of pharazon's true intentions
like he pretends like he's going along with his
wife Muriel who's his cousin they also reference
that during the episode too we're getting into
Game of Thrones twin says territory here marrying
within the family and one of the big things about
his character though is that we really only know
about some of the big plot points like we know
that he is the person who ordered the attack on
valinor and led to the downfall of numenor he fell
to sauron's influence listened to his advice and
served morgoth but like that's about it so the
show is trying to expand on that like show you
how he eventually came to those decisions what
he actually did to eventually see his power on
numenor that's his whole thing like he's biting
his time he has this whole speech about following
the tide listening to the tides he's waiting for
his moment to pounce to seize power from his wife
we also find out that his aide is actually his
son it could be his son from before he married
Muriel because he doesn't look like her that much
their whole scene is loaded with foreshadowing for
the downfall he mentions tide rising and drowning
a man that is literally what happens during the
downfall of numenor we just saw that in last
week's episode he reveals his grand plan is to
use the coming War to position themselves better
with the eventual rulers like the people of Middle
Earth and use that against the elves to slowly
push them out eventually subjugate them like
that's what he means when he says eventually we'll
be the ones ruling the elves he's like a slightly
less chaotic version of Littlefinger on the show
we also find out that halbrand got his wish at
least temporarily working for the forge master
that was this whole thing in the first couple
of episodes he's also started wearing numenorian
clothing the reason they asked for his help with
the map in adar's forces is because he's from the
Southland so he knows the area he knows where all
the points of interest are all the defensible
positions and that's basically where they're
sending the new menorions to that particular area
they'll probably arrive just in the same way the
Gandalf's reinforcements arrived during The Battle
of Helm's Deep like just in time for the tide to
turn the only thing about this whole battle in
the last two episodes with the tower is that we
know that Mordor is eventually going to be created
So eventually Adar will be successful eventually
Mount Doom has to erupt Sauron has to return and
be successful so we think what's probably going to
wind up happening the last couple of episodes
just based on what they're foreshadowing here
is the numenorians meteor man will arrive to
help them but they'll just barely rescue the
southlanders who are at the tower But ultimately
they'll lose the Southlands 2 outer like Adar will
be successful Mount Doom will erupt at the end of
the season it'll be like a big WTF Cliffhanger but
there's been most of the episode with Galadriel
trying to win over Halbrand and even though the
show's using him as like a version of Aragorn
like The Reluctant King I think he's meant to
be much more of a tragic character than Aragorn
was because of what eventually does happen in
the timeline with the creation of Mordor and
sauron's return and the creation of the Nazgul
the nine Kings of Men they had that short scene
of Galadriel teaching the other numenoriansome
orc fighting skills just meant to show you some
of her Battle Tactics you have to remember she
was commander of the Elven armies in the north and
she's been alive for thousands of years so she's
had a long time to practice her skills they also
try to show you a little bit of how brands skills
too like we haven't actually seen him in battle
but I believe that we'll see that the last couple
of episodes like he does actually have some skills
up in the tower Muriel's father the previous
King tar palantir keeps talking about the coming
darkness which is another reference to Sauron and
the downfall of numenor when we go back to Meteor
Man and he's fixing himself using another spell
the ice spell the language that he's Whispering
is in quenya the language of the elves and like
I said earlier he's just trying to heal his mortal
body but he goes a little too far like he's just
not used to taking this body for a spin so to
speak it's like driving a new car he's basically
like this Cosmic Angel this hugely powerful being
trapped in a mortal body then during the scene of
Duran with the elves there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs and references when he references
the noldor those are the elves who answered the
call of the Valar to journey to valinor in the
earliest of days most of the elves when they
were first created came from this place over
here I explained this in my video last week when I
talked about how the Orcs were created so morgoth
actually found the elves here before the Valar
did he stole some of them and turned them into the
Works which is one of the reasons why I think
that Adar cares about them so much and why they
call him father because he was probably related
to some of those elves so like these Orcs would
literally be his descendants when they reference
the Khazad that's obviously the group of people
who created khazad doom the original Duran they've
changed some of the backstory behind the kings of
khazad dum it's not like a traditional type of
bloodline where like the son of the previous
King becomes the next king Duran's folk this group
of dwarves have this belief about Reincarnation of
the original Duran so each new king of kazad
doom becomes the person that they think is
The Reincarnation of Duran they have this whole
prophecy about how he's going to be reincarnated
six times when they mention Aule that's the
Valar known as the Smith who created the doors
like he literally created the Dwarven Rays he's
also the Valar who Sauron studied craftsmanship
under so very relevant because that's how Sauron
learned to create the rings of power sauron's big
skill in addition to shape-shifting he had a
lot of magic as well as a Mayar but his other
major skill was in making things they explained
later in the episode though this whole sob story
that during the fourth tells about the history of
the table and the burial rights of their people
their monuments was a whole lie just to stick
it to them like he was just having a little bit
of fun with them but then gilgala tells this big
story about the original creation of mithril and
why the elves believe that they have an ancestral
right to it that's much stronger than they claim
the dwarves make to it when he references the song
The Hithaeglir. The Hithaeglir is their word for
the Misty Mountains that's what they call them and
the legend is the creation of mithril he says that
this ancient elf was trying to find one of the
Lost silmarells which was in a tree and fought
a balrog for it and it was the combination
of the power of the silmaril the balrog's
dark power interacting with the tree that created
mithril so when they talk about the light shining
in the myth roll that's meant to be the light
of the silmarils and gil galad's whole plan is
to use the forge to saturate the elves with this
light to help preserve their Realms and themselves
that's also how sauron winds up tricking the
elves into creating the rings of power because
that's literally one of the side effects of the
Rings is preserving things I also think that what
they're trying to foreshadow is them using mithril
in the creation of the actual rings of power like
they use mithboro to forge the Rings themselves
the whole thing with the blight that's affecting
Linden like it's rotting the tree out here like
this is just the beginning eventually the rest
of the forest in around Linden will look like this
is meant to be a reference to the growing darkness
of sauron's return like everything is slowly being
perverted gilgallot also makes another huge star
on reference when he mentions the eye of Hope
like the eye of Sauron Sauron also offers the
elves false hope deceiving them into creating
the rings of power then we see farazan's son
sabotaging the boat although isildura gets mixed
up with it like I said I think they're trying to
show him being more morally gray giving you
an idea for why he would eventually fall to
the influence of the One Ring like when given the
choice to end all potential for evil why wouldn't
someone throw that one ring of power into the
fires of Mount Doom well it's because he has a
little bit of darkness in him then they give us
another history lesson when celebrimbor starts
talking about erwan's father he reveals that he
was there the night that elrond's father set sail
to valinor breaking the ban of the Valar in order
to convince them to join the war of Wrath which
they did it was successful but it ended tragically
for elron's father because he basically lived out
the rest of his days sailing through the sky just
watching over destined to never again set foot on
the earth like The Valor had to punish him for
what he did Breaking the ban celebrimbor also
mentions his mother there's actually a statue of
both his mother and father in the bay in numenor
there's a story about how his mother was changed
into a dove I Believe by the Valar and there's a
dove on the statue's shoulder that's meant to be
his mother the man is his father he has a silmaril
in his forehead but they're trying to give you
this whole vibe with the elves here like Gil
Galad and celebrimbor that they're doing terrible
things in the name of Last Resort like everyone is
getting a little bit dark because there's no other
path they can see to their goal and it's all part
of Sauron and morgoth's plan spreading the in
influence of evil around the world like it's a
slippery slope you do one kind of bad thing you do
another bad thing eventually you turn into a dark
elf like Adar elrond also references that when
he's talking to Duran at the end of the episode
instead of breaking his oath he convinces him to
help give the elves mithril but it's when he's
talking about what happens to the elves if their
light actually does diminish in them like their
Immortal Souls will wither and they'll diminish
into nothing more than Shadows of themselves which
is a reference to Adar himself like earlier in the
episode he was talking about The Light Within him
the warmth that he felt diminishing eventually
and when he talks about the elves having to
leave Middle earth eventually most the elves
do wind up leaving Middle Earth elrond himself
eventually winds up leaving Middle Earth but the
whole thing with Jordan agreeing to help the elves
give them mithril I think it's just a reference
to them actually creating the rings of power like
eventually they do have to get their hands on
mithril somehow then Galadriel has this big call
to action speech with Halbrand he's afraid that
he's falling to the same fate as his ancestors
who serve morgoth he references his own dark past
and the terrible things he did to survive which is
kind of ironic because he talks about the other
southlanders casting him out they'll hate what
I've done but like half of them literally just
joined the forces of Sauron and Adar so like
half of them probably won't even care what he did
galadriel's speech about touching the darkness
in order to find the light is also a reference to
what her brother told her when she was young when
he asked her what she knows of Darkness that's
also a reference to what her brother did the
Sons of feyenoor all of the Elven kinslang like
there was a lot of dark things that the elves did
especially the sons of feyenoor then they finally
confirmed that idar is not meant to be a version
of Sauron and they tease this weird relationship
between him and Sauron like he kind of hates
Sauron even though it seems like they're on the
same side when the old man swears his Allegiance
he calls Sim Sauron and atar gets really pissed
off I think that's because the whole idea that
just because they were all on the same side they
all served morgoth like the whole idea is that Mor
goth into the top of the Pyramid of evil here sarn
was just his chief Lieutenant he had other people
following him it sounds like Adar was one of them
but it sounds like all of morgoth's generals just
were not super best friends or anything like that
but they had all their own reasons for following
him so even though everything that Adar is doing
seems like it's helping Sauron achieve his goal
it sounds like why he's really doing this is to
benefit the Orcs like he's doing this all to give
the Orcs a place to live because it seems like the
only thing that he really cares about is the Orcs
themselves and like I said I think that gets into
the original creation of the Orcs the way that
morgoth created them how they used to be elves
and Adar being related to those original Orcs
why else would they call him father if not for
that so just a reminder that even though Sauron
eventually winds up winning the day so to speak
like eventually Mordor is created Adar isn't doing
this to directly benefit Sauron he's doing this
to benefit the Orcs also R.I.P Taro and Theo's
friend there that's what you get for throwing
in your lot with the forces of morgoth they also
reveal morgoth's sword is on a monument in the
Elven Tower held by one of the ancient Kings of
the Southlands probably Halbrand's ancestor that
served morgoth and when he calls the sword a key
it's probably the key to making Mount Doom
erupt like covering the Southlands and Ash
blotting out the Sun like Adar said in his evil
guy monologue at the beginning of the episode I
think the whole idea is that Adar wants to take
the blade plunge it somewhere place it somewhere
magical somewhere important and that will cause
Mount Doom to erupt and they'll probably end
the season on that like holy crap and then boom
slam to credits we'll explain what happens next
in season two and when he references the ticking
clock on this like it could be days moments before
they attack I think the idea is that it'll be like
the last two episodes will be their version of The
Battle of Helm's Deep at this particular Tower
with the other forces like the numenoreans and
the meteor man showing up to help them by the
end he also references the sinking of baleria
during the war of Wrath which we saw in the
first episode when he says whole continent
sank during the war with morgoth you could also
call that foreshadowing for the eventual downfall
of numero the sinking of numenor the horrors
that he talks about the blade unleashing are
probably literally the fires of Mount Doom and at
the end of the episode they skip over how Brand's
meeting with Muriel but they reveal that he did
answer galadriel's call to action he's wearing
numenorian armor the faithful depart esilder wins
his place amongst them for his deception gladriel
is also wearing her own different numenorian armor
that's the star of Arendell on their chest it's
a numenorian symbol and they end the episode
over the credits with that next song everyone
posts all your theories in the comments though
like where do you think they're taking this in
the last couple of episodes I think one of the
other things that they're teasing is that by the
end of season one they'll finish the creation
of celebrimbor's Tower Forge so like we won't
actually see Sauron show up on the show physically
either to like maybe a teaser at the end of season
1 or during season two and they won't actually
create the rings of power themselves until into
Season Two Season three like some future season
if you spotted any other Easter eggs or references
in the episode that I didn't talk about in the
video just write down below in the comments in
my full episode sixth video will post next week
after they release it everyone click here for my
new house of the Dragon episode 6 video and click
here for my House the Dragon Dance of the Dragons
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!